اعلن نائب رئيس الوزراء التشيكيه فاق
وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيين على تحديد سقف
لسعر الغاز والاتفاق كذلك على اليه
التنفيذ وقال الوزير تشيكيا الاتفاق سي
يفعلوا بشكل الي اذا استمر سعر الغاز لمده
ثلاثه ايام في تجاوز حاجز 180 يورو لكل
ميجاوات في الساعه واضاف في مؤتمر صحفي
بروكسل لان التسعيره سيكون مرينا لان
الهدف هو ضمان الامدادات واستقرار الاسواق
الماليه واكد نائب رئيس الوزراء التشيكي
انه سيتم ايقاف الاليه بشكل تلقائيا اذا
انخفض الاستهلاك عن السعر المعروض واذا
تعرضت امدادات الغاز للخطر من جانبها قالت
مفوضه الاتحاد الاوروبي لشؤون الطاقه ان
الاتحاد جاهز لايقاف اليه تسعير الغاز اذا
رات المؤسسات الماليه اثرا سلبيا على
الاسواق مؤكدا الاستمرار في تقليل
الاعتماد الاوروبي على روسيا
على القرار الاوروبي اعلن ان سقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي لاسعار الغاز هو هجوم على اليه
تحديد السوق للسعر وهو غير مقبول اذا اعلن
الكريملين رفضه للقرار الاوروبي بتحديد
سعر همم اقصى لي الغاز معنى من بروكسل
مراسله للجزيره عبد الله الشامي لمزيد من
التفاصيل عن هذه الاليه عن السعر همم
المتفق عليه والمخاوف التي يبدو انها
تنتاب الدول الاوروبيه رغم اتفاقها على
هذا السعر او هذا الصقر
حسن يمكن ان نقول ان الاوروبيين اليوم
توصلوا الى ما كان اا كما يقول نائب رئيس
وزراء تشيكي امرا مستحيلا قبل عده ايام هو
ما يسميه القطعه الاخيره في عقده الطاقه
اي ان الجميع الان خرج من هذا الاجتماع
بتوافق حول امرين الاول هو السعر الذي
سيتم تطبيقه لمده ثلاث ايام متتاليه اذا
ما تجاوز الاستهلاك ااه السعر الذي تم
الاتفاق عليه اي 180 يورو للميجاوات في
الساعه لكن من ناحيه اخرى
ضمانات وتطميات واعطيت للدول التي كانت
ترفض في الاساس سقف السعر ان نتحدث عن
المانيا وهولندا
انه اذا انخفض الاستهلاك عن هذه السعر
لمده ثلاث ايام بين الاليه يتم ايقافها
بشكل الي ولكن ربما الاهم من ذلك ايضا هو
انه اذا رات المؤسسات همم الماليه
الاوروبيه البنك المركزي الاوروبي ومعه
اختلف المؤسسات الماليه في دول الاتحاد ان
هذا الامر قد يضر بها او يضر بامدادات
الغاز فانه سيتم ايضا ايقاف الاليه بشكل
الالي وبالتالي الاتفاق اليوم كان ليس فقط
على السعر وانما ايضا على الضمانات كذلك
على تاخير موعد بدء تطبيق السقف لمده 45
يوم اضافيه انه بدلا من الاول من يناير
سيبدا في الخامس عشر من فبراير من العام
المقبل بشكل عام المزيد من التفاصيل حول
الاليه نفسها وردت في البيان الذي اصدرته
رئاسه تشيكيه بعد انتهاء الاجتماع الذي
استمر لما يزيد عن تسع ساعات اليوم الحديد
كان ايضا في هذا البيان عن ان
العقود الاجله التي يتم تطبيقها في المنصه
الهولنديه التي تستخدم في التسعيرات تعرف
باسم التيتي اف هذه العقود ايضا اذا ما
راى الاتحاد ان حاجياته لا يعني لا يتم
تلبيتها فانها ستكون لاغيه في ناحيه اخرى
ايضا الموقف او ربما الاستباق الاوروبي
فيما يخص رد الفعل الروسي الحديث عن ان
الاوروبيين على حسب مفوضه الطاقه
الاوروبيه بالفعل استغنى وبشكل كبير عن
الطاقه الروسيه الاستهلاك همم الوارد من
روسيا قل الى ما دون السبع بالمئه مقارنه
ب 49% مطلع هذا العام وبالتالي الاوروبيون
اليوم على ما يبدو ليس فقط من هذه
التصريحات الصحفيه وانما ايضا تصريحات
الوزراء الذين خرجنا اجتماع وكان على
ابرزهم وزير الطاقه الالماني بان الامر او
الاجتماع كل المخاوف الاوروبيه سواء تلك
التي تطالب بالسقف او حتى الاخرى التي ترى
ربما امكانيه وجود شح دادات الاوروبيون
يقولون ايضا ان هذا الامر اذا ما تم
تطبيقه سيكون فقط ل 20 يوما ثم يعاد النظر
كل 20 يوم في هذا السعر
لنفهم الموضوع اكثر بصراحه همم عبد الله
همم
هنا ماذا يعني تحديد سعر الغاز اذا اذا
رفضت روسيا مثلا همم هذا الامر ورفضت هذا
السعر الذي يعرضه او تعرضه الدول
الاوروبيه وقررت ان لا تورد الغاز مطلقا
هل هناك يعني همم رد فعل او اليه معينه
لهكذا احتمال من الاوروبيين
حسن نفس الاهليه التي تعلن عنها اليوم هي
نفسها التي منذ تقريبا ثلاثه اسابيع تم
الاعلان عنها ايضا فيما يخص السقف سعر
النفط الروسي وايضا سقف السعر العالم
عموما للنفط الذي يمكن ان يشتريه الاتحاد
الاليه في كلا الحالتين يتعتمد على ما
يسمى بالاقتصاد بالعقود الاجله ان
الاوروبيين يشترون الغاز او النفط بعقود
محدده السعر مسبقا للاشهر القادمه وليست
الانيه وبالتالي الامر يكون متفق عليه
بشكل مسبق لاننا عندما نتحدث الان عن هذا
السقف بما يخص الغاز سيكون الامر للشهور
المقبله اي همم بشهور فبراير وما بعدها
وليس شهر يناير لان هذه العقود عاده ما
تكون قد انتهت في البورصه الامر الاخر هو
ان كل من الغاز والنفط سواء من روسي او من
غيرها من المصادر يجب ان يشمل بخدمات
التامين وغيرها من خدمات الحمايه التي
بطبيعه الحال هذه كانت التي تقدم هذه
الخدمات هي متواجده هنا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالتحديد لوكسمبورغ والنمسا
وغيرها من الدول التي تعتمد على الضمانه
الماليه كمصدر لهذه الشركات بالتالي اذا
ما قررت هذه الشركات انتت الشركات الروسيه
في هذه الحال ان تبيع لن يتم اعطائها ربما
هذه الخدمات التي لا يمكن لاي ناقله سواء
الناقله تحمل النفط او غاز انت مر عبر
المياه الاوروبيه الا ان كانت تحمل او
حصلت على بوليصه التامين من احد هذه
الشركات وبالتالي الاتحاد الاوروبي ربما
يضغط على روسيا من الناحيه التي لا تستطيع
التعامل معها في هذه الحاله خصوصا انها
ملزمه العبور عبر المهن الاوروبيه للوصول
الى الدول الثالثه
من الغاز يستورد من روسيا بعد ما تخلت
معظم الدول الاوروبيه عن
الحجم الاكبر ربما من الغاز الروسي
يكون هذا الاتفاق موجه اكثر اذا كانت
روسيا فقط لا تورد اكثر من سبعه بالمئه من
احتياجات الاتحاد الاوروبي من الغاز
الاتفاق بشكل عام هو لجميع الموردين ليس
فقط الروس بالطبع الاسئله التي كانت على
لسان كثير من الصحفيين وكذلك الخبراء
الاقتصاديين في الفتره الماضيه هي عن ذات
الامر هي ان انه اذا كانت روسيا بالفعل
همم قد قللت من ما تمد به الاتحاد
الاوروبي بشكل كبير فالى من اذا توجه هذه
الاسعار او هذا استقبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
يبدو انه سواء في هذه الحاله او في حاله
النفط سقف اسعار النفط يريد ان يدخل في
مرحله التجربه نعلم انه مثلا في مساله
النفط هناك مرحله 45 يوم تبدا من الاول من
يناير وبعدها سيتم تقييم الاسعار هذا
الامر ايضا اليوم يتحدث عن ان السقف سيتم
ل 20 يوما وبعده ايضا سيتم التقييم
وبالتالي اتحاد ربما هو يجد نفسه بين
امرين الامر هو نقص الامتدادات التي كانت
تاتي من روسيا التي كانت بطابعه الحال
جغرافيه تستطيع ان تمد الاتحاد بطلباته
بالشكل السريع وفوري ولكن الموارد الاخرى
تبقى للاتحاد في الاعتماد عليها لازالت
ستستغرق كثير من الوقت ان يتحدث عن ربما
اعوام
1424 وما بعدها ليكون هناك مصادر كامله
يتم الحصول عليها من خارج دول الاتحاد
الجزائر قطر وغيرها من الدول التي تم
توقيع اتفاقات معها وبالتالي اوروبي ربما
يريد ان لا يضغط على نفسه باسعار لا
يستطيع تلبيتها لان الدول التي ارادت هذا
السقف تحدثت عن عدم قدرتها على تربيه
احتياجات الشركات والمؤسسات وعن انها ايضا
عندما بدا العام عندما تم وضع موازنات
الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي خصوصا
الدول الجنوب التي تعد الاقل دخله مقارنه
بدون الشمال لم يكن في الاعتبار ان حربا
وان هناك ضغوط اقتصاديه ستكون على
المؤسسات وعلى الافراد طيب ستبقى معنا
بطبيعه هلال عبد الله الشامي من بروكسل
لمتابعه هذا